[Music]
that was an amazing piece of
calculation that easily dominated his
rivals
when in game after game the opposition
has never been as
heated as qdrc most tournaments in the
[Music]
world
hello everyone and welcome to the 2020
u.s chess championships over the next
month
you'll see america's best battle for
national titles
and a prize fund totaling more than 330
000 while the coveted pandemic keeps us
from being together in person
i'm happy to be joined virtually by the
past present
and future of american checks my name is
tony rich and i'm the executive director
of the st
louis chess club we've been organizing
and sponsoring national championships
since 2009 and
i must admit this one looks quite
different normally the opening ceremony
day would be filled with last minute
details
making sure the flower arrangements are
set dgt boards are wired and tested
and spectator areas are stocked with
snacks and drinks
while we can't be together this year in
person we can enjoy watching these
talented players
at the top of their fields battle it out
while hearing the play-by-play from our
commentators yasser sarawan
alejandro ramirez maurice ashley and
jennifer
shahadi jeanne singfield is the
co-founder of the st
louis chess club she's been a lifelong
supporter of scouts bsa
and was instrumental in the creation of
the merit badge for chess
what some of you may not know is that
she's also a published chess author
with more details and other words of
encouragement for the players
i ask now that you give your attention
to dr jeanne singfield
i'd like to welcome the best chess
players in the u.s
who are playing in five tournaments
based on chess ratings and tournament
success
this includes a u.s girls junior
championship
the u.s chess junior championship
the us chess senior championship
the u.s women's chess championship and
the u.s
chess championship now thanks go out to
the st
louis chess club and spectrum studio
and kevin here for arranging these
online tournaments and the streaming of
games
this makes my husband rex who i call the
godfather of american chess
very happy i'm also very happy to see
the increase in chess
in the u.s over 250 000
scouts have earned the chess merit badge
the st louis chess club has also been
focusing on finding and growing
american chess through videos classes
and hundreds of tournaments to help
beginners and support
chess coaches i wrote a booklet last
year entire
entitled learn to read and write chess
chess literacy is necessary to play in
these tournaments
this year the st louis chess club in
addition to making the english version
available for free on their website
is offering the booklet for free in
seven other languages
that includes dutch romanian indonesian
french spanish german and filipino
so big thanks to my chess friends for
these
translations i did help on the
indonesian version
so now normally i get to ring the bell
and start the tournament but
i have a problem with that so here is my
solution
my uh scouts
made me a chess set on a laser
you can see this and so i'm going to
make the opening move
e4 so let's have fun
with the tournaments good luck everyone
and bobby fischer did say e4 is best by
test so thanks jeannie
you know genie's husband rex has been a
driving force in american chess since at
least 2008
um you know rex learned the game when he
was a youngster and he even had the
opportunity to meet bobby fischer in the
1970s
after his retirement from dimensional
fund advisors rex moved back to the area
and founded the saint louis chess club
and since the club opened and with the
support of dr jeanne and raxingfield
st louis has truly become the epicenter
of american chess
now this is exciting you guys probably
have heard
that we have um announced plans for an
expansion last year
but the trust club has actually taken
over some of the space going down the
corner of our block here
it's been exciting to watch the process
unfold and with more details please
welcome
the founder of the chess club rex
singfield
welcome players and everyone for the
2020 u.s
chess championships deanie and i wish
that these tournaments could be played
at the st
louis chess club in its usual classical
format
however we are grateful that the
championships are not cancelled
but are being played online in a rapid
format
although 2020 has been a challenging
year
for most in some manner jeannie and i
hope that we can brighten the chess
world by announcing
the 20 000 square foot expansion
of the st louis chess club to give a
quick overview of what will happen
king side diner will be moving across
the street at the corner of euclid and
maryland
in the former gambling space the chess
club will then expand
east and west into existing kingside
diner space
and the farmer brennan's space in the
former culprit space on the corner there
will be a new
small place chest-themed restaurant and
the farmer froyo space
will be a new entrance with an elevator
for the expansion
we estimate that construction will be
completed by spring summer of 2021
and hope that the tournament space will
be ready for the 2021
u.s championships again i wish you were
all here in person
but we'll have to wait until next year
to see everyone
good luck to all of you and i look
forward to watching some exciting chess
this month thank you
i can't tell you how exciting the
expansion is i mean really it's a dream
come true it's probably the biggest news
that has come out of the st louis chess
club since we opened 12 years ago
so once the world allows it and we're
able to be back together in person
i can't wait to welcome you all to st
louis to check out the new and improved
st louis chess club now with a few words
and well wishes please welcome missouri
governor mike parson
hi i'm governor mike parson and here in
missouri
we are proud to host along with the st
louis chess club
this world champion 2020 championship
chess matches it will be today i want to
thank everybody for taking part in this
virtual event
and i want to wish all the people that's
been involved in the five tournaments
the best of luck in the days to come
thank you and god bless
now we've talked a lot about the five
national championships but really let's
dig
into some of the details and get into
what these events really are
first of all this year's u.s
championships instead of being classical
chess will be rapid chess
in a round-robin format are all play all
the u.s
girls junior championship the us junior
championship and the u.s senior
championship are each nine rounds
three days three rounds per day the u.s
women's championship and the u.s
championship tack an extra day on
with three rounds per day over four days
now as i mentioned this is a rapid
chess tournament which means the time
control is much faster
the players will be competing at a time
control of a game in 25 minutes
with a five-second increment and don't
worry you ultimately will see a winner
of all of these championships
because playoffs are happening we will
crown our
national champions now our first event
that we'll kick off with is the u.s
girls junior championship it's a new
event that started in 2017 here at the
st louis chess club
this year the event runs friday through
sunday october 9th through the 11th
and features a ten thousand dollar prize
fund there's an additional
six thousand dollar scholarship to the
winner of this tournament
thanks to the generous support of u.s
chess and the dwayne barber foundation
now let me introduce some of these young
talented girls to you
we'll start off with the reigning u.s
girls junior champion that's
international master karissa yip
we also have international master annie
wang women's grand master jennifer u
women's international master emily
nguyen women's international master
talia cervantes women's fiate master
martha samarashvili who is the reigning
national girls tournament of champions
winner women's international master
rochelle wu
women's feed a master sophie morris
suzuki
women's candidate master rui yang yan
and the wild card pick for this
tournament is women's candidate master
alice lee now in just a moment we're
going to take a peek into the players
meeting from about an hour ago
where the competitors drew lots now
drawing lots is important because it
sets the stage
for who will play whom what order and
with which color
but before we dig into that let's take a
look at how last year's
u.s girls junior championship went down
the 2020 u.s girls junior championship
features 10 of the strongest female
chess players in america
under the age of 20. over the course of
nine rounds
these competitors will battle for ten
thousand three hundred dollars in prize
money
and bragging rights as the best young
female player in the united states
last year's defending champion karissa
yip won the 3 thousand dollar first
place prize
with an impressive score of seven and a
half out of nine
with 13 year old michelle wu finishing
just a half a point behind
with annie wang the 2018 women's
championship runner-up
and jennifer yu the 2019 women's
champion now joining the fray
the incredible field will make this
year's girls junior championship
a hotly contested event
girls what you're going to do is when i
call your name
you're going to choose a color and a
piece set
you can see that we have the white
pieces at the top and the black pieces
at the bottom
and we have five different pieces and so
when i call your name you're going to
just call out a piece and a caller
so this is the us girls junior
championship
drawing of lots and first up i would
like to invite
carissa yip who i believe is the
defending champion in this event
so carissa can you please go ahead and
select a color
and a piece please um i'll take a black
knight black knight so carissa wants
this one which is the black knight
and carissa your pairing number is going
to be number seven
all right next on the list i have annie
wang annie can you go ahead and
choose one of the remaining pieces and
colors please uh can i take the white
fish up
white bishop that's this one up here and
that's pairing number 10 for you
next we have jennifer you jennifer can
you go ahead and please choose a piece
and a cola
oh can i get the black robe black
rick right there that's number one
uh talia cervantes you're
next up please so please go ahead and
choose one of the remaining pieces and
colors
i'll take the white king white king
white king is number eight emily nguyen
uh emily can you go ahead and choose the
next one please
um white rook white rook
here's number nine uh martha
samadashvili
martha can you choose a piece please um
i'll have the black bishop
black bishop that's pairing number two
uh rue yang yan rouyan can you please go
ahead and choose a piece
uh the white knight white knight
is pairing number six
sophie morris suzuki can you please go
ahead and choose a piece
white queen the white queen
here's prank number five rochelle wu
you're next i'll take the black team
black king he's pairing number three and
that leaves alice lee
alice i assume you want the black queen
yes okay
and that's pairing number four so that
concludes the
pairing numbers for the us girls junior
championship
all right so that means friday we'll see
the following matchups
in the first round
on board one hanging the white pieces
will be reigning u.s women's champion
jennifer yu against annie wang martha
samarashvili will play the white pieces
against emily nguyen
rochelle wu will have white against st
louis and talia cervantes
alice lee will have the white pieces
against carissa yip
and finally sophie morris suzuki will
have the white pieces against
ruin yan that all starts on this friday
it'll be very exciting to watch
now i first met our next speaker lyda
crewson
when she was the older woman of the
central west end in 2017 lydia became
the city's first female mayor
replacing the long-term mayor francis
slay
now a lot of the players on here are
probably reacting because they remember
uh mayor slay always being at the
opening and closing ceremonies
his excitement and congratulations that
he would share with all of the players
and we're honest to have that torch
passed now to our new mayor of the city
of st
louis and i'm proud to welcome mayor
lida crewson with some warm words of her
own
hi i'm lida cruz and mayor of the city
of st louis
on behalf of the city i would like to
welcome all
players wherever you are across the
nation to the 2020 u.s
chess championships virtually
right here in saint louis although you
are not able to play
physically here at the saint louis chess
club in the central west end
we are so excited that the competition
is online
we the city of st louis are so thrilled
to host and support
this national competition during these
very interesting times
i'd like to thank the fields for their
vision and support
of not only the city of saint louis but
of my neighborhood
in the central west end and the chess
club of st
louis we the city of st louis wish all
of you the very best of luck
over the next month as you compete in
five u.s
championship competitions thank you and
good luck
our next event is the u.s junior
championship
now that's a tournament that started in
1966
in fact you'll see some of the previous
winners here in our uh
tile of player pictures including larry
christensen
patrick wolf takara nakamura and ray
robson this year's junior championship
will be october 13th
through the 15th and features a 20 000
prize fund
additionally here we have another six
thousand dollar scholarship to award
thanks to the generous support of dwayne
barber in u.s
chess our players this year are
star-studded and it starts off
with the 2700 plus prodigy chess player
grand master jeffrey zhang
and also we have grand masters sam
sevion and john
burke international master praveen
balakrishnan
international master joshua shang grand
master brandon jacobson
our wild card pick for the tournament
international master
christopher u the u.s junior open
champion
day master christopher shen and finally
the danker tournament champion
international master bryce tiglin i
would like to point out and uh recognize
the 2019 u.s
junior champion awander liang who was
unable to compete this year in the
junior championship
but he will make his qualifier
appearance and take that spot
in the u.s championship later this month
just as we saw with the girls junior
championship
these junior players drew lots a while
ago we'll check that out but first
let's look back at last year's event
the 2020 u.s junior championship
features 10 of the strongest chess
players in america
under the age of 20. over the course of
nine rounds
these competitors will battle for twenty
thousand six hundred dollars in prize
money
and bragging rights as the best young
player in the united states
this year's competitive field will
showcase seven players who are among the
top
100 juniors on the planet including
world number five sam savion
and world number two jeffrey zhang who
won the world junior championship
in 2016. the future of us chess
is on full display in what should be an
intense battle
all the way to the finish line
[Music]
yes so this is the u.s junior
championship
drawing of lots and i'd like to start
with
um the i think the defending champion is
not actually playing
uh in the u.s junior this year so we're
going to start down the reagan list and
go with jeffrey jean
jeffrey if you can go ahead and please
choose the press piece
uh white rook white rook
and that is pairing number eight uh sam
sevien if you can please go ahead and
choose the next one um
the black queen black queen
pairing number ten john burke you're
next on my list john if you could go
ahead and choose a piece please
the white queen the white queen right
number three
nicholas checker nicholas can you go
ahead and choose a piece please
i have the black king please yep
the black king is number five brandon
jacobson brandon if you could choose a
piece please
uh black fishes black bishop
he's number six uh praveen balakrishnan
ravine if you could choose a piece
please
white king hearing number seven
joshua shang can you please choose a
piece
give me that white bishop bishop
is number nine christopher you
can you please white knight
is number one um bryce tickling
bryce if you can choose a piece please
black knight please
knight is number two and christopher
shen
i
and that is indeed fairing number four
and that concludes the drawing of lots
for the us junior championship
now don't forget the us junior
championship starts on october
13th and whenever we begin with round
one these are the pairings that we'll
see
starting off with the white pieces we
have international master christopher yu
against grand master sam
sevi bryce tiglin will have white
against joshua shang
john burke will play the white pieces
against jeffrey zhang
christopher shen will square off against
praveen bella krishnan
and nicholas cecca will face off against
brandon
jacobson those are some pretty exciting
pairings i know the kids are going to be
preparing and studying and working
really hard uh to be able to
uh do their best in these championships
so
speaking of which i'd like to take a
couple of moments now just to ask some
questions of a couple of the players in
the fields here
um i'll start off with patrick wolfe uh
who's competing in the u.s senior
championship
um you know as i mentioned earlier in
this uh this opening ceremony patrick
was actually one of the players to win
the u.s junior championship and he did
so
in 1987. uh he then of course went on to
win the u.s championship too a couple of
times so
not too bad uh not too bad there patrick
my question that i have for you is
really related to these junior players
in the junior events
what advice would you have for the up
and coming junior players
well today might be that discussion now
what's that patrick am i being asked now
what advice do i have
you're live you're in the hot seat let's
see what you have to say
so what i'm sorry can you repeat the
question what advice do i have for the
junior players is that what you were
saying
exactly right um actually i'd like
to ask them for advice but
uh no i i think just uh just keep doing
what you're doing
have fun and um and i'll be watching
your games for good opening ideas
they always say that the junior players
are on top of the openings and the
current novelties and
theories of the day so thank you very
much for that patrick
next question i have is for one of the
youngsters carissa yep
the reigning us girls junior champion
carissa my question for you
is what has life been like during the
pandemic
what's changed school your chest
studying your friends
how has life changed for you
looks like carissa has become larry
christensen in this moment but uh
uh maybe maybe we'll ask larry a
question larry you know you're one of
those guys who is a
um i mean a legend in american chess
your skills and your talent
in fact i remember whenever you used to
do the the the
national simuls with church's chicken
you know the the good old days
can you tell me um uh i think from your
perspective
i'm sorry uh we'll come back to you
larry just a moment chris he hears me
now
carissa did you ask my question what's
changing
um what was the question again can you
tell me how your life has changed now
during the pandemic with school and
chess and your friends
how is life different during the
pandemic uh
yeah so i'm basically just at home all
the time now
and uh school has been like pretty busy
for me so i actually haven't had
much time for chess and stuff i guess i
shouldn't have let my competitors know
that
unless i'm trying to psych you guys out
you may never know
but yeah um i miss my friends a lot but
you know i'm trying to
quarantine self quarantine say stay like
socially distant from people
until the whole pandemic is over
so what is it like with your friends
then carissa are you
spending time on zoom meetings with them
or playing games online how do you stay
in touch
oh yeah i like facetime them um all the
time we like do homework together
chat it's not really the same as like in
real life
interaction but for the meantime
it's good enough i understand that i
think we all share your sentiment it is
right now all we can hope for is good
enough until we can all get through this
crazy pandemic i do want to go back to
larry christensen though because
i had an important question i'd like to
ask you larry the
the u.s senior championship field or
senior players in general
have really done some amazing things in
the past few years i think you guys have
won
the the world senior team championship
three years running
um you know obviously we have a lot of
very strong talent what do you attribute
that to how do you
attribute this golden age of senior
chess in the united states
and while we get larry back i just want
to remind you that the senior
championship will be october
17th through the 19th and features 50
000
rises back again go ahead so we have a
great night we have a very talented
large group of uh talented seniors and
way up to the uh the mid 70s i think jim
tarjan's
tearing up the playing fields of europe
he was a little bit
and uh we just have a good active smart
uh
uh group of uh very talented young you
know seniors
so do you think uh there's something to
be said about the fact that our seniors
um like i said have won the past three
um
world senior team championships you seem
to have a lot of camaraderie amongst the
teams too there's a lot of jovial nature
and everybody seems to really get along
is that the truth or is this all just
for show no it's all that's fake
that's what awesome we all all hate each
other
really in private in the reality it's
all voice war
but we put on we put on a good show for
the public
that's really what it is that you
certainly do it is quite a show and we
can't wait to get into that
before we dig into the senior champion
yeah before we dig into the senior
championship though um
our next guest is carol meyer cara meyer
took the reins as the executive director
of u.s
chess in 2017 as she put it at a time of
unprecedented excellent um in 2017 we
won the gold medal at the olympiad and
azerbaijan
and our young players just claimed four
world championship titles
at the world cadet in world youth
championships
carol and us chess has been have been
wonderful partners with the st
louis chess club from scholastics to
national championships and everything in
between
so it's my pleasure now to welcome
executive director of u.s chefs carol
meyer
it's a pleasure to be asked to
participate in this year's virtual
opening ceremony for the u.s
chess championships what a lineup of
events over the next
almost three weeks showcasing us chess's
top talent
at the highest level of the game us
chess is grateful to the st louis chess
club for working with us
to ensure these important events
continued in spite of challenging
circumstances this year
we have every confidence in the club for
its ability to hold these events
in a way that honors the game and
ensures its integrity
the st louis chess club has created an
unprecedented legacy of support for our
top players
this year is no different on behalf of
us chess
i'd like to personally thank rex and
jeannie singfield for their commitment
to the game along with the wonderful
team led by joy bray
and tony rich that make these events so
special
i'd also like to thank dwayne barber who
along with us
chess is providing matching funds for
the first place scholarship
for the u.s junior and u.s junior girls
events
i look forward to tuning in beginning
october 9th
to watch some great games and to see the
ultimate crowning of the 2020 us
champion and the 2020 u.s women's
champion
thank you for making this year's events
possible and i wish every player good
luck
in all their games
so i mentioned this uh resurgence of
senior chess especially here in the
united states
and one of the events that have spurred
that along was the new
u.s senior championship that just
started last year here at the st louis
chess club
uh the event is october 17th through
19th this year and as i mentioned
there's 50 000 on the line our senior
championship field
is the star-studded list of every chess
player you've ever heard of from the
united states including
grand master larry christensen grand
master gregory
kaidanov grand master igor novakov the
reigning u.s senior champion grand
master alex shabalov
grand master alexander golden
grandmaster patrick wolf
who maybe hasn't played so much active
chess over the past few years
but is certainly a force to be wet
reckoned with grandmaster joel benjamin
the wild card pick for this event grand
master alex yermalinsky
the u.s senior open champion from 2019
grand master dimitri gurvich and we
round out the field with the u.s senior
tournament of champions winner
p-day master shelby gets
and now it's the seniors turn let's
check out the inaugural u.s senior
championship from last year and then
we'll dive right into the drawing of
lots
the 2020 u.s senior championship
features 10
of the strongest chess players in
america over the age of 50.
over the course of nine rounds some of
the most decorated players in u.s
history
will do battle for the prize fund of 50
000
this field of accomplished veterans
which includes 2019 champion
alexander shabalov has racked up 13 u.s
championships
27 world open victories and numerous
olympiad appearances between them
championship dna will be on full display
in a tournament where
every participant knows what it takes to
bring home
a major title
um so this is the u.s senior
championship drawing of lots and i am
going to start with the
defending champion i believe is
alexander chavalla
alexander if you can please go ahead and
choose the first piece
black bishop you want the black bishop
and you are preparing number eight and
now i'm going to go down in
reading this daughter so larry
christiansen larry if you can choose a
piece please
larry are you there oh
white king sorry white king sounds okay
senior morning
we've we've got we've got some time
so and then igor novikov if you can
choose the next piece please
oh white discipline white bishop
and that is pairing number five uh
patrick wolfe
uh patrick if you can choose a piece
please uh blackrook
blackrook and you are pairing number 10
now we're going to go to gregory
kaidanov next gregory if you can choose
a piece please
white root please the white brook
is pairing number one alexander golden
uh if you can choose a piece please
white knight please
white knight and that's pairing number
nine for you
uh joel benjamin if you can choose a
piece please
black knight black knight is
praying number three uh alex yamalinsky
alex can you choose a piece please black
kingplist
black pink preparing number four uh
dimitri girvich if you could choose the
next one please
black queen black queen is pairing
number two
and that leaves shelby gets shelby if
you can choose a piece
uh i don't have a clue okay
white queen queen and we will give you
pairing number seven
thank you very much that concludes the
drawing of lots for the 2020 u.s senior
championship
round one of the u.s senior championship
will begin on october
17th don't forget to tune in and watch
all the action
and let's see what those round one
pairings will be starting with the white
pieces we have grand master gregory
kaidanov
against grandmaster patrick wolf dmitry
gurvich will face off against alexander
golden
joel benjamin will have the white pieces
against alex shabala
while alex yermalinsky will square off
against shelby getz
we wrap up the u.s senior championship
field with igor novokov having the white
pieces
against larry christensen so don't
forget tune in october 17th
to follow all of your favorite u.s
senior championship players
and all of the action here live now a
tournament that we have
next is the u.s women's chess
championship it dates back to 1937
and it was actually one of our first
national events that we held here at the
club
this year's event will begin october
21st and run through the 24th
and will include a hundred thousand
dollar prize fund
the field is star-studded as well and
includes some of the best female players
in the country
we start off with grand master irena
crush international master anna zatonski
the reigning u.s girls junior champion
women's grandmaster karissa yip women's
grandmaster tatev abrahamian
international master annie wang women's
grandmaster jennifer yu
who is the reigning u.s women's champion
women's international master emily
nguyen
women's grand master sabina foyser
women's international master ashriefla
esvaran women's international master
talia cervantes
and international master dorsa derek
shawnee as a wildcard pick
and our final wild card pick is women's
feed a master
martha samadash field you know it was
exciting last year to watch young
jennifer you win her first
u.s women's championship let's uh take a
look at her road to victory and check
out
this year's drawing of odds
the 2020 u.s women's championship will
showcase 12 of the strongest female
chess players
in the united states over the course of
11 rounds this elite group of chess
fighters
will compete for a prize fund of one
hundred thousand dollars
reigning champion jennifer you will
attempt to repeat her magical run from
last year
it's a really strong tournament and i've
never
done this well before so but seven-time
champion arena crush
four-time champion anna zatonski and the
rest of a strong group of competitors
will look to prove which queen should
stand atop
this year's throne
so as you've seen now um ladies we've
added
pawns to the selection choices
so that you can so that we have 12
drawing of lots
and i'm going to start with the current
defending champion
who i believe is jennifer you so
jennifer
if you can go ahead and please select
the first
i have piece white pawn pink the white
pawn
and the white pawn is pairing number
seven
uh irina crush if you can choose the
next one
uh can i have the black pawn please sure
that is pairing number nine and now anna
zatonski
the white king the white king
number five and carissa
um i'll take the black king the black
king
praying number six annie wang
can i take the white rook please white
brook
here's number ten uh
black bishop black bishop is praying
number one
and talia cervantes
white bishop white bishop
alright number 12. emily win
i'm going to listen to a white knight
please wait no yeah sure
praying number three uh darsa
derek shona
can you select a piece please
is dorso here
elsa can you hear me
we can't hear her she's talking but she
doesn't realize we can't hear her
right tulsa we can't seem to hear you
right now if you'd like to type it to me
you can go ahead and type it in the chat
white queen okay so dosa chose
the white queen and that is pairing
number eleven
ash rita s warren black knight please
black knight is pairing number four
uh sabina foyza uh black queen please
black queen that one pairing number two
and martha samadash really black brook
uh blackrook is preparing number eight
thank you ladies
the us women's championship will begin
on october 21st
and don't forget you can always tune in
to uschesschamps.com
to follow all of these events with the
great grand master commentary team that
we have
jennifer shahadi yasser sarawan maurice
ashley and alejandro ramirez
so let's take a look at what the u.s
women's championship
head-to-head matchups will be for round
one starting with the white pieces
we have tatev abrahamian against talia
cervantes
sabina feuger against dorsa derek
shawnee
emily winn will face off against annie
wang
ashrita s will run will have the white
pieces against irina crush
anna zatonski will play against martha
samarashvili
and karissa yep will square off against
jennifer yu
starting on october 21st the us women's
championship is always one of the most
exciting events that we hold here in st
louis so don't forget to tune in now
introducing gary kasparov
it's an honor that never gets old uh the
13th world chess champion
kasparov has been a force both on and
off the board
his contributions to the game go far
beyond the novelties sacrifices
and other over-the-board achievements to
his credit gary kimovich
is the driving force behind the grand
chess tour and continues to be one of
the game's greatest
ambassadors please welcome legendary
world champion
gary kasparov
hello everyone and welcome to the 2020
us chess championships
i wish we could all be there together in
saint louis in person
i'm sure we all wish we could be just
about anywhere in person
but of course saint louis has a special
place
in the hearts of every chess player
thanks to rex and ginny singfield
the chess club and scholastic center of
saint louis has turned their home city
into the global chess capital and the
united states into a global chess
powerhouse
this year the us championships all of
them
girls seniors and opens take another
bold step
into the new world of prestigious online
rapid events
when my website hosted the first online
super tournament 20 years ago
it was considered a strange spectacle
but this generation of players
grew up with online chess usually before
they ever
saw a wooden chessboard just watch out
for those
mouse sleeps guys i can say from painful
personal experience
chess has always adapted to the times
which is why it is still popular
after a thousand years and despite
increasing competition
for our attention when i was growing up
in baku
in the 60s and 70s there wasn't much
else to do other than chess
today we're seeing a new generation
embrace new technology and chess is
reaching a whole new audience
but to my ear nakai streaming and
twitching
sounds like maybe caught the disease
even worse than covet
so call me an old traditionalist but i
hope
to see everyone back otb or
over the board soon in san luis
until then best of luck to all the
players
and their internet providers
the first national event that we ever
held here in st louis was in fact
the us chess championship you know
that year was so amazing it was 2009 we
had 24 players
we had a great arbiting staff we had
commentary that was audio only
we were really flying by the seat of our
pants but i think what made it such a
great event
is realizing how amazing this chess
community is you know bringing all of
these people to st
louis it's really like an extended
family for us here
and so we're really proud to be able to
continue that tradition this year
the us championship will kick off on
october 26
and features a 150 000 prize fund
i mean whenever i say a star-studded
field in those previous events
just pump the brakes there because here
we have some super grand masters
including wesley so
grandmaster linear dominguez the u.s
reigning u.s
champion grand master hikaru nakamura
grand master jeffrey zhang
grand master sam savion grand master ray
robson
grand master daria spiers grand master
sam savion
grand master and st louis resident alex
lenderman
the reigning u.s junior champion grand
master awander liang
the wild card pick for this event grand
master alejandro ramirez
and the winner of the us open grand
master el shawn
moore diaboti you know and for our final
walk down memory lane
let's take a look at what happened in
the u.s championship in 2019.
12 of the strongest chess players in
america are hungry and ready to fight to
the bitter end
in the 2020 u.s chess championship over
the course of 11 rounds
these competitors will battle for prize
money totaling
150 thousand dollars in 2019
hikaru nakamura took home a remarkable
fifth title
yeah i mean i think this one was really
difficult because uh
i had so many games that i felt were
must win and i found a way to win every
single one of them
but with past champions wesley soh and
sam shanklin leading a powerful cadre
of chess warriors it's anyone's guess
who will win this year's championship
and for our final drawing of lots we
decided to take an
analog approach uh in this digital world
so let's take a look at what pairing
numbers the players drew
so this is the um the version
of the drawing of lots that hopefully is
not as simple as finding a url and
clicking on it
so uh let's recreate the wheel so
gentlemen this is the
2020 us championship drawing of lots and
again we'll start with the
defending champion hikaru nakamura
hikara if you can go ahead and choose a
piece and a color please
for white rock so we're gonna go with a
white rook
and that is a queen which is actually
number 12.
uh so wesley if you can choose the next
one please yeah i have the
black pawn
my black pawn is actually number six
[Music]
all right and lenny if you can choose
the next one please
oh white knight right now
um and that is number one
uh jeffrey if you can go ahead and
choose next one please wait bishop
bishop and that is number four
uh sam if you can go ahead and choose
the next one please
i'll take the black king please
say black king yes please
and that is actually number 10
uh rare your next please white queen
white queen tonight is number five
uh sam sevian please blackrook
blackberry
number two
and darius schwartz if you can choose
the next one please
black queen that's the jack which is
number 11.
uh alex lenderman please white bomb
white pawn and that is pairing number
seven
uh a wonder black knight
black knight
and that is pairing number nine
and alejandro please a black bishop
black bishop that's pairing number eight
and el shen the last one for you
thank you the only guy can say thank you
it's me
number three
thank you gentlemen for your
understanding and that concludes the
drawing of lots for the
us championship
you can watch these joggernauts battle
it out beginning on october
26th we will begin round one promptly at
1 pm
central time and let's take a look at
what those round one pairings will be
all right actually it's going to be a
surprise for everyone we'll make sure
that we get the pairings for the
uh us championship round one posted on
uschestchamps.com
uh-huh here we go let's take a look at
what the round one pairings are we'll
start off with
grand master linear dominguez against
grand master hikaru nakamura
sam savian will have the white pieces
against darius spears
el shawn moradia body will square off
against sam shanklin
while jeffrey zhang is paired against a
wander liang
ray robson starts with white against
alejandra ramirez and we wrap up with
wesley so as white
against alex lenderman don't forget all
of that action begins october 26th
with our great commentary team on
uschestchamps.com
so next up really i'd like to ask the
player some questions
um you know we put out some social media
feelers and we asked for questions from
our
chess media and from fans and audience
members alike out there
um so i'll start off and maybe just pick
on a couple of players and ask some
questions
i'd like to begin with grand master
hikaru nakamura the reigning u.s
champion hikaru i mean this year you
have uh blown up on twitch just like
uh some of the seniors were mentioning
it's uh a different world from whenever
they were playing chess
how much do you attribute your your
recent twitch success
to the covet pandemic lockdown and the
fact that everybody's just yearning for
more and more content like this
yeah well first of all i would like to
give a big shout out to mostly most of
the people who are playing in the
seniors because i played against many of
them when i was younger and i was
growing up like people like joel
larry uh dimitri i played them many
times when i was younger i think a lot
of
my success in improving as a chessler is
due to play against players like them so
first they deserve a lot of credit for
all they did for american chess um
in terms of twitch and uh and growing
the community for chess online i think
certainly covet played a big role but i
think more than anything you have to
realize there are a lot of people who
have been exposed to chess
throughout their lifetime and um the
fact that many people had more
time where they were at home they had
more time to rediscover their their
loves and things that they enjoyed when
they were younger i think played a big
role and so a lot of people
flocked the internet they saw the chess
content that i was pr providing along
with other streamers and i think they
enjoyed it and i'm just really glad
there's so many people who have
rekindled their love and their interest
in the great game of chess
awesome thank you so much ricardo uh my
next question that i have
is for irina crush grand master
uh many time u.s women's champion i
don't have the number off the top of my
head
seven i think it is or something at this
point irina um
you know you're one of the the folks
here unfortunately who actually did
suffer through
through covid you were infected early on
in the the pandemic
can you tell me what it was like and
what your recovery has been since then
yeah that's a long story tony um
i mean you know it's hard it was hard to
breathe
it was hard to breathe it was a lot of
you know chest pain
it was just hard to i mean yeah i don't
really want to
talk about it too much um but i mean i
feel i feel good enough to play i mean
yeah of course i still have a lot of
these remaining symptoms and um
you know who knows when they'll go away
but um definitely looking forward to
just thinking about something else and
playing chess
in a couple of weeks we definitely wish
you well and hope for a
speedy recovery with no bumps in the
road so thank you so much for being the
fierce competitor that you are in these
events
uh my next question is for
let's go with grand master awander liang
uh wander
is the reigning u.s junior champion uh
now for those of you who aren't aware
winning the junior championship
qualifies you to play in the next year's
u.s
championship so a wonder enters this
field of 12 as one of the maybe
lower rated players uh and uh he's got a
lot to prove ahead of him
i wonder can you tell me what your
preparation has been like and what your
hopes are for the u.s championship
i'm not sure that a wonder can hear me
or maybe he's just being really
thoughtful and coming up with a
deep answer you know as these chess
players do they say whenever you find a
good move
sit and wait and find a better move so
maybe a wanderer's just coming up with a
better answer than he had before
well in the meantime maybe we can can
move along um i would like to ask
maybe let's go with alice yeah i mean
it's great to play in the u.s
championship
um obviously i've been preparing just
like
uh everybody else so um i think
i'm sorry wonder go ahead
um i'm sorry i'm unmuted
can you guys hear me now
yes we can go ahead wonder
yes welcome to online these are some of
the technical glitches that uh
they come up from time to time but that
is just life during the covid pandemic
i wonder maybe we'll come back to you in
just a little bit once we have this
worked out i think i've got just one
more question and i'd like to pose it to
a very young competitor in the u.s girls
junior championship alice lee
alice is the wild card competitor in
this event
alice can you tell me what you miss most
about
chess during the pandemic most about
what do you miss about over the board
trust during this pandemic
uh can you repeat that please
sure uh what do you miss most about
chess
real chess over the board chess i'll say
um during the pandemic since you've been
kind of
locked well i'm still glad that
um we can play online chess that it's
there so
um well we can still play um but i guess
i missed a social interaction
with playing the chess do you
uh play chess with your friends in
school normally or what are some of the
things that maybe you have uh
missed out on because of the kobe
pandemic
well um in person chess
is one thing and um another thing
is um i guess it's mostly just social
interactions
um but at least we can still function
uh so it's fine right now me
it's true and we will all get through
this for sure alice best of luck in the
upcoming us girls
junior championship uh now everyone it's
time for me to say goodbye
um i'll take a moment here and just make
a personal statement
i really mean it whenever i say these
players are like our extended family
whenever the us championship and the
women's championship were supposed to
happen in april
i was sitting in my house when the
junior and the girls in the senior
championship were supposed to be
happening here
in july i was sitting in my house much
like all of you were
i can't wait for the day where we can
all be back in person playing chess over
the board
every time we have the national
championships in st louis it feels like
a big extended family reunion
and i'm looking forward to being able to
have that again
so let me uh finish things now by saying
that you can always follow all the
action for these major events
on uschesschamps.com we have an amazing
commentary team with grand master
alejandro ramirez
jennifer shahadi yasser sarwan and
maurice ashley
we'll kick things off tomorrow with the
girls junior championship at 1 pm
central time
don't forget to tune in and thanks for
joining us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you